Professor: Ai, que...
Professor: Luljeia.
Professor: Vamos até lá.
Professor: Um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um
Professor: Deixando-o esta vida mais...
Professor: Descermos, senhor, diamante.
Professor: Mousa.
Aluno: O que a gente pode fazer?
Professor: O frio de...
Professor: Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do professor e dos alunos. Fala do
Aluno: Hoje eu me reficcinei ao aluno.
Professor: Deito de um.
Aluno: O que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o
Professor: Fala do professor e dos alunos.
Aluno: E aí, o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o que é o